>> Jesse: OF FULL-BLOWN REVOLT
AGAINST ULTRA WOKE GEORGE CUT
STONE.
AN ASTOUNDING 98% OF LOS ANGELES
PROSECUTORS SUPPORT A RECALL
AGAINST THEIR HYPER PROGRESSIVE
BOSS.
HE'S'S STRUGGLING TO SAVE FACE
AFTER GIVING A LIGHT SENTENCE TO
A CHILD MOLESTER CAUGHT ON TAPE
CELEBRATING THE D.A.'S POLICY
THAT SPARED HER YEARS BEHIND
BARS DESPITE ATTACKING A
10-YEAR-OLD GIRL.
>> DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
I'M GOING TO PLEAD GUILTY, THEY
WILL PUT ME ON PROBATION, AND
IT'S GOING TO BE DROPPED, IT
WILL BE DROPPED.
>> FOR AN OFFENDER COME YOU
DON'T HAVE TO REGISTER?
>> I DON'T HAVE TO DO ANY OF
THAT.
>> Geraldo: HE CLAIMS HE
DIDN'T KNOW, WHO NOW IDENTIFIES
COME AS YOU MAY HAVE FIGURED
OUT, AS A WOMAN.
BUT THE PROSECUTOR ON THE CASE
WHO HANDLED THIS SAYS THAT HIS
INNER CIRCLE ALL KNEW ABOUT THE
SHOCKING JAILHOUSE AUDIO.
>> I RECEIVED AN EMAIL SAYING
THAT MANAGEMENT WANTED THE
TAPES.
THEY HEARD I HAVE THE TAPES
BECAUSE I SENT THEM TO EVERYBODY
INVOLVED IN THE TUB'S CASE.
EVERYBODY THAT NEEDED TO KNOW.
I SENT THEM A LINK.
>> RATHER THAN FOCUS ON THE
D.A., I'M GOING TO FOCUS ON THE
PERP HERE.
HANNAH TUBBS, WHO WAS JAMES
TUBBS AT THE TIME THIS WAS
COMMITTED.
HE DIDN'T IDENTIFY AS A WOMAN
UNTIL HE WAS FACING -- WHAT HE
THOUGHT WAS A LIFE SENTENCE.
SOME CLAIM THAT THESE ARE GAMING
SPORTS.
IF THEY'RE GOING TO GAME THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM, I THINK
THIS IS A REAL POSSIBILITY THAT
WE SHOULD HAVE OUR EYES OPEN TO.
THE FACT THAT JAMES TUBBS FACING
LONG TIME BECOMES HANNAH TUBBS,
GETS THE SYMPATHY OF THE TRANS
ASPECT.
AT THE SAME TIME, HE SAID AT THE
TIME I WAS HUNGRY FOR SOME MEAT
BEFORE GOING OUT --
>> Jesse: THAT WORKS WITH
GASCON.
SOMEBODY'S GOING TO HAVE TO ASK
THEM NOT.
THE GUY IS A SICKO AND EVERYBODY
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN ABOUT THESE
TAPES.
THE ONLY REASON THAT HE REVERSED
THIS WHOLE DEAL IS BECAUSE FOX
WAS GOING TO BREAK IT.
SO THE GUY'S A TOTAL MEDIA
FRONTRUNNER.
AND HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED.
REMEMBER THE HOME INVASION OF
THE MOTOWN COFOUNDER WHERE THE
WIFE WAS SHOT DEAD?
THAT AND I BELIEVE THE UCLA GIRL
THAT WAS STABBED TO DEATH BY THE
HOMELESS PERP BY A SLEW OF
FELONY CONDITIONS.
THOSE TWO THINGS HAVE
GALVANIZED, NOT JUST RIGHT-WING
DONORS, BUT NOW LEFT-WING DONORS
IN THAT WHOLE AREA.
THEY ARE COMING OUT OF THE
WOODWORK TO RECALL THE SUCKER.
YOU NOW HAVE GEORGE CLOONEY'S
PRODUCER, YOU HAVE
HILLARY CLINTON'S BUNDLER, YOU
HAVE BIDEN'S PICK FOR THE
AMBASSADOR TO NORWAY.
BILL CLINTON'S FRIEND -- YOU
HAVE SUGAR RAY LEONARD, ROSANNA
CUT, THEY WANT TO RECALL THIS
GUY.
SO NOW THIS IS NOT EVEN ABOUT
POLITICS.
THESE ARE ABOUT PEOPLE WHO LIVE
IN THIS AREA AND CAN'T HANDLE
THIS GUY ANYMORE.
I THINK THIS REALLY SIGNALS THAT
HE IS TOAST.
>> Geraldo: WHEN THE RECALL
ELECTION HAD ITS FIRST RUSH,
IT'LL MAKE UP 40% OF THE VOTES
IT NEEDED.
>> Dana: THIS IS GOOD LESSON
IN POLITICS BEING LOCAL.
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO, A VERY
RADICAL PORTION OF THE LEFT
DECIDED THAT THEY WANTED TO GET
A BUNCH OF DAs DOCKED BY
GEORGE SOROS INTO PLACES LIKE
L.A., NEW YORK, SAN FRANCISCO.
AND THEY DID IT WITH TONS OF
MONEY AND UNDER THE RADAR
BECAUSE PEOPLE WEREN'T PAYING
ATTENTION.
NOW IT'S BODY BAG STOCKED UP AND
PEOPLE GETTING KILLED.
PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO PAY
ATTENTION AND TRYING TO RECALL
THEM.
THEY WERE NECESSARILY
REPRESENTATION OF WHAT PEOPLE
THOUGHT WHEN THEY WERE GETTING
SOMEWHAT PROGRESSIVE ABOUT THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
BUT OVERALL, THE PHILOSOPHY HAS
BEEN PROVEN THAT THE SAYS THAT
SAYS THIS LEFTIST IDEOLOGY
ACADEMIC PHILOSOPHY ABOUT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM AND IT'S
CRASHING RIGHT INTO REALITY OF
WHAT CRIMINALS ACTUALLY DO TO
PEOPLE WHEN THEY ARE ALLOWED TO
JUST GET OUT OF JAIL AND SHOOT
PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES WITHOUT
ANY CONSEQUENCES.
BUT IS THIS KIND OF PHILOSOPHY
THAT'S BEEN IMPLEMENTED WITH
REAL-WORLD CONSEQUENCES WITH
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN KILLED AND
WHOSE LIVES HAVE BEEN CHANGED
FOREVER.
>> Geraldo: AND YET WE DON'T
LIKE THEY KNOW WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST POPULATION OF IN JAILS
AROUND THE WORLD.
>> Dana: WE CAN ARREST
CRIMINALS.
THE THING ABOUT THE INTERNAL
REVOLT, BILL MILLER'S COME ON
REPORTER IN L.A., HE FINDS OUT
THAT THESE TAPES EXIST.
THAT'S WHEN THEY STARTED
BACKPEDALING.
GASCON HAS NO FRIENDS ANYMORE.
HE SHOULD RESIGN TOMORROW.
THE OTHER THING YOU SAW, THE
GENTLEMAN WE SAW THE CASE, HE
GOT REASSIGNED AFTER HE BROUGHT
THOSE TAPES TO EVERYONE'S
ATTENTION.
THAT IS THE KIND OF RETALIATION,
THE KIND OF PROSECUTOR THAT THEY
PROVIDED TO SOMEBODY WHO'S
WORKING HARD TO TRY TO DO THE
RIGHT THING.
THAT IS WHY 98% OF THE
PROSECUTORS WHO WORK FOR THEM DO
NOT HAVE TRUST IN HIM.
>> EVERY GOING BACK TO 1994?
>> 98%.
VLADIMIR PUTIN COULDN'T EVEN GET
THAT.
YOU ARE RIGHT, HE'S DONE.
I DON'T SEE HOW HE FINDS HIS WAY
THROUGH THIS.
WE WERE ALREADY THERE, WE WERE
ALREADY THERE IN NEW YORK CITY.
WE ARE MOVING BACK IN THAT
DIRECTION.
THE POLICE ARE COMPLETELY
DEMORALIZED.
NO ONE UNDERSTOOD THE POWER --
AXES BECOME A LAWYER IS
UNDERSTOOD.
REGULAR PEOPLE NEVER UNDERSTOOD
THE POWER OF THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY.
THAT 90% OF CASES ARE PLEADED
OUT AND WHO THAT DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IS MEANS THOSE PEOPLE
EITHER GET STIFF SENTENCES AND
ACTUAL JAIL TIME OR THEY ARE LET
OUT TIME AFTER TIME AFTER TIME.
JESSIE, YOU LAID OUT THAT LIST
OF CELEBRITIES AND I KNOW YOU
KNOW THIS, THEY DESERVE NO
CREDIT.
THIS IS ALL NOT IN MY BACKYARD
STUFF.
IF IT WAS ON THE OTHER SIDE,
THEY BE PUTTING OUT VIDEOS ABOUT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
IT JUST HAPPENS TO BE IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
WILL THEY LEARN A LESSON?
PROBABLY NOT.
BUT HITTING THEM WITH THE BALLOT
BOX, MAYBE THEY WILL THINK
OTHERWISE.
>> Geraldo: ARE WE GOING TO DO
THIS STORY TODAY ABOUT TRUMPS
PROSECUTORS NOT LEAVING,
RESIGNING?
>> Dana: NOT IN THIS
PARTICULAR SHOW, BUT IT HAS BEEN
ON THE AIR.
>> Geraldo: THEY RESIGNED --
EFFECTIVELY DROPPING THAT
INVESTIGATION WHI